300 families over 1 000 orphans are
going to benefit please help me reach my
target now
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter download
the qurani app now and have a ramadan
with allah's book like you've never had
before
okay guys so i've stopped
it
done i'm done okay sorry hey stop for my
time
okay so there's impossible
existence for example you can't have a
square
square triangle
right right it's an impossible assistant
you have possible existence
and you have necessary existence yeah
possible existence are like
me you and him yeah
i'm breaking it down so impossible
existence is a triangle can you have a
triangle circle or triangle square no
it's an impossible existence so we have
possible existence which are people like
me you
etc and then we have a necessary
existence yeah
and we have necessary existence right
which i'm going to prove that that is
good almighty okay so now the example
i'm going to give is the following i
want to start off with google
google in order for its existence it
relies on the
internet okay so what we'll say is it
relies on
the internet
what does the internet rely for its
existence
ipad phone computer
okay let's say computers yeah
computers what does a computer rely on
for its existence you mentioned it
electricity
electricity
sorry my bad i forgot to screen record
yeah there we go
so electricity yeah electricity
now
google is a dependent
thing it depends on something else in
existence which is the internet so
google depends on the internet for its
existence the internet depends on what
the computer for its existence right
so google depends on the internet
internet depends on the computer the
computer depends on electricity
now
the electricity relies on solar panels
and us human beings yeah so it relies on
humans
for its existence
now what do we rely on food
shelter sleep etc yeah so as you can see
the chain is growing
etc etc now
if we have an
indefinite infinite amount of dependent
things will have the fallacy of infinite
regress meaning
we need a necessary being for everything
to make sense now this necessary being
which has to be independent so what did
we say we are dependent beings we need
an independent being in order for us to
be alive that makes sense an example
that i usually give
is
a
seabed so this is the sea right
and we have a lot of creatures living in
there fishes
can we ever have
sea and all the christian side without
the seabed
so the analogy that i'm giving here is
that the seabed is everything the sea
and creatures fall back on
right
so what we say is that because we live
in this world and there's we're all
dependent beings we necessarily require
an independent self-sufficient being in
order for everything to make sense
right and you guys know
for nothing nothing comes right
can we can we ever get something without
nothing
okay so what we say is just because we
cannot get it from nothing therefore
something has one of them has to cause
us
which we call god
in a nutshell now
is there any way that you believe i may
have been wrong
in this argument i know something that
has a human form or like that that will
communicate with us in the first place
who's that you're talking about god yeah
why would god have a human form or okay
or even want to talk to humans you know
like yeah why would he specify the earth
is like a particular importance to it
okay maybe
busy building the whole universe why do
we matter
that's a very very interesting question
you know you said something very
interesting actually have you guys seen
that video where it shows our planet
compared to the sun
compared to like the universe i've seen
that videos it's profound right so we're
like a little speck so now we don't
believe as muslims that god is a human
being he's not a man there's nothing
like him yeah he's self-sufficient so we
don't say he's a man that you know some
christians believe he's jesus et cetera
well the question you said is why would
you want to communicate with us now the
question is very important something so
amazing which
is god almighty the fact that he cares
about us so much that we're a little
speck but he wants guidance for us and
he wants us to know our purpose and why
we're here yeah so yes you might say why
would something so magnificent even care
about us but the fact that he cares
about us shows about his mercy because i
believe god is the most merciful he's
the most trust he's the most wise he's
all-knowing right
so but in a nutshell do you guys accept
that we all have to depend on something
independent which has to be good
because otherwise it doesn't make sense
for us to be here
basically like you said that there's a
bunch of things that have been caused by
an initial cause yes
why does that take why is that of
consciousness we don't actually like
have a personality or what we relate to
ourselves it's like except just having
compassion like that's not necessarily
true just because there's an initial
cause that could be a rock full of good
good good so what that means is for
example that you guys
would accept the premise of being a
deist meaning there is some kind of
power but why wouldn't it be a rock but
what we say is that in our universe
there is intelligence
there is power there is knowledge
that's what the person the independent
being which is god almighty he has to be
the designer he has to be intelligent
because how can we have those properties
in our universe
but god doesn't have those properties
how can i give rise to something that i
do not myself
oh that's why that's where evolution
fits in because
the point is the most intelligent beings
survive and so over time you get more
and more intelligent beings okay so you
find
you know societies like we have today
of course but if you think about it
evolution talks about for example the
first cell
the first cell where did that come from
even if you go to evolution yeah
evolution is not random events happening
there's order
yeah there's things happening so for
example our point is the first cell that
was made where did that first cell came
from which was my argument that cannot
come from nothing so they've already
replicated um the first cells like in
laboratory in laboratories if you apply
electricity to chemicals like correct
you can actually create
self-replication well you know what
they're doing it's like for example i
give you 20 pounds you found the 20
pounds rather than thanking me and you
make without 20 pounds you make more 20
pounds they're using the cell that god
made to replicate more the credit goes
to god not them what they're doing is
good they're replicating it they're
using electricity to play rather
i'm with that i'm well well and good but
you're taking the credit of god imagine
that would you guys
it's also it's shown that there is an
explanation that it doesn't rely on god
no but it does because the fact that the
first cell exists where did the first
cell come from it cannot come from
nothing and the first one is quite a
complex uh property here we're not
talking about just like a liquid liquid
it's called you know dna inside it and a
branch of other stuff and we know how
the dna works it's the reason why you
look the way you look and the way i look
and the way you look yeah dna is
something that is a property that's a
working machine like this book has
information in it right
information requires intelligence
the dna is more complex than all these
books put together so so your argument
basically is that because something's
highly complicated yeah it can't be
explained through any means other than
intelligent being making well not
necessarily because then you would say
okay well god almighty is more complex
than design does he require a creator my
point is this if there is design it
requires a designer
because the best possible explanation to
that is where did the first cell come
from which is quite complex that it gave
life that scientists today are
replicated by that and even when it
comes to airplanes we learned to make
these things via other things like the
flies the birds we look at how things
work we are looking at god's creation
but what we do we're giving credit to
scientists like what field do you guys
work
in
yeah imagine you do a university essay
and you get a star and i'm sure you guys
do yeah i'll pray for you guys
imagine somebody took credit for that
and said you know what i did it bridget
she copied from me how would you feel
so how do you think with god almighty
where
people are giving credit to things that
he has created yeah
do you know that god is the creator of
these things rather than theories
okay
okay but when we talk about the big bang
we're going to a point of initial
explosion
no no but this shows existence of god
you know why because what you're seeing
is there was an explosion
yeah and the universe is expanding and
we go to a single point where there's
some scientists say that it was about
the size of an orange you're telling me
that everything within this universe was
the size of an orange the point is what
created that caused it there's theories
that have developed now where it says
just that there was a universe before
that oh yeah
and then it contracted and actually
became the size of that and then just
okay
that's called the multiverse theory or
it's called the steady state theory yeah
the point is this even if that's the
case there are one million universes the
point is this the fact that there are a
million universes
what caused that universe exist because
what was our premise something cannot
come from nothing
so those universes either
what are they were they always there
i feel like this is a problem
a lot of belief systems is based on the
fact that there has to be a starting
point but there has to be but not
necessarily but do you have evidence
that's a fallacy to assume that time had
a beginning
okay so do you have any evidence
let me ask you this it's time ever going
to end
this time
we accept infinite post eternally but
not pre-eternally because what that
means is because we believe in hell and
heaven but the hell in heaven depends on
god so post eternally this way
god created let's suppose our universe
from here yeah okay god has always
existed yeah god almighty's always
existed the question we're asking is
what caused it people say oh it came
from nothing that's an impossibility
from nothing nothing comes came by
chance what kind of chance it's always
been there prove to me you have to prove
to me the concept of infinite if you say
it was always there this possible
infinite doesn't exist in the real world
there's no such thing as infinite in our
real world
actual
mathematics there's possible infinity
potential infinite but i'm talking about
there is no concept of that what we got
back to is the big bang and what we're
seeing is what caused it to explode
so are you are you claiming that are you
saying that it's a big jump to say that
there has to be a deity or something do
you think is that like yeah no no no no
no no no no no there's a lot and there's
a lot like none of it
no no but the thing is but the thing is
when it comes to rationality and logic
that is the best explanation for example
we know it cannot come from nothing so
therefore we have to accept that
something was caused we should accept it
okay remember
yeah i just think yeah yeah
enough too okay i'm saying
i think you have a good argument but i
don't think that's definitive proof to
like there is a god it could have been
anything okay
so like
even if you're right and there was a god
and there's a first god like
why you know
there's so many religions like and you
know i grew up in a mormon church for
like 16 years i was fully convinced
no one's
no one's beliefs could tell me any
different that i was wrong
you know
in reality there's so many different
gods and different forms that the star
of the universe can take okay what we
see is that
i'm so sorry and how would we know about
god like
something that we've made up okay so
what we say is that look i'm not talking
about religion i put religion to a side
for now what i want to do is i want to
establish if god exists or not i'm going
for the best possible explanation with
our logic because when we wake up we use
our rational logic on a day-to-day basis
you guys came here today why because he
said let's visit speaker's corner you
gave yourself a purpose you put your
shoes on you came here you didn't wake
up and say maybe i'm in the matrix let's
go speak his corner hey what's maker's
corner it doesn't exist am i here you
didn't do that you went with your best
logical explanation of i exist and
that's what renee uh the car said here i
i think therefore i am yeah so meaning
that you woke up you use your rational
logic to put your shoes on have
breakfast get ready wear a nice shirt
like this yeah you went in the mirror
you went in there you went in the mirror
and said look i'm gonna look smart you
gave yourself a purpose with a nice
jeans are you guys a couple by the way
yeah okay good if you get married call
me to your wedding please
so the point is this yeah i'm just
trying to say even you guys coming
together
you know what you was attracted to where
she was attracted to you use logic and
rationality to build a relationship what
we're seeing is use the same logic and
rationality say hold on a second
it cannot come from nothing therefore it
requires a cause now you can have a
right to say hold on a second ali okay a
creator exists but how is it you have a
right to ask that i'm not going down
that route yet what i'm just saying is
does it make
plausible sense to the best explanation
that a creator exists
no i'm still not convinced that there
was an initial thing you know like so
you believe it was always there
there's there's you know there's no
evidence to suggest either way so why
should i but what we do we do have
evidence we don't have evidence for
cause and effect but we haven't
theoretically let that make sense that
there has to be you know in our
understanding of things it has to be a
first thing i don't think we can
comprehend the fact that maybe time is
endless no no but time is irrelevant so
for example if i have an empty glass
this is empty bottle if i say if we give
this infinite amount of time i would
have a chocolate cheesecake with four
strawberries on it the point is this
time is irrelevant to the question
because the elements to make a chocolate
cheesecake with four strawberries are
not in the bottle so giving it time
saying infinite or billionaire is
irrelevant to the equation because the
elements to make the cheesecake is not
in there so what i'm trying to say is to
say if you give it this time or that
time this will happen
it's not relevant to the equation here
i'm trying to see what if what if
hypothetically yeah the universe began
and it didn't begin it's just always
been there and there were just a lot of
nutrients a lot of minerals
all this stuff in the universe
that just eventually just came together
and just made the world
okay but the point is this yet
why do you go to that example which we
don't have infinite infinite doesn't
exist in the real world we know there's
an expansion of the universe it's
expanding so if we rewind it has to go
to a singular point yeah and even there
it's like what caused it what you're
seeing is that it was always there so
you're saying it is
sorry
what you saying here is that it was
always there infinite you have to prove
that
does infinite exist in the real world
i'll give you an example i don't have to
prove it though because i'm not relying
on
you know i'm i'm not relying on a
concept of a humanist kind of god you
know i don't know
when i'm not trying to establish
religion i'm just basing one religion
no i'm not talking about god is religion
no no no no no no no no i'm not talking
about religion yeah
no no but first we need establishment
god exists then religion is the next
step
if i have an infinite amount of bananas
and i
eat two
how many bananas do i have
that's that's that's contradictory
because infinite has no
you can't have infinite plus one or
infinite minus two it conjugates
infinite my point is the following we
know infinite doesn't exist in the real
world there's no such thing as anything
in the real world therefore if we don't
have the explanation and we know by
logic that from nothing nothing comes
it requires us to logically accept that
there was a cause someone called
something caused it not a man i'm not
saying it's a human
because i feel like this question is
perhaps the biggest
indication
that there is a god because like it's
very difficult to answer you know i mean
if there is an initial point in the
universe what caused that thing
i don't know like that analogy of
bananas doesn't really relate to the
concept of time like well if you have an
infinite amount of time you take away
two seconds how much time does it like
that doesn't make sense but that's what
i'm trying to say like for example god
almighty tells us that he takes an oath
by time he says i am time so what we're
trying to say is that god has always
existed which was my first
explanation about the independent being
his independence self-sufficient we are
dependent on food and other elements and
our universe is dependent on things he
is the
sea bed that everything falls back on
and is independent so he is infinite i
accept that time was not created for him
what we're trying to say is but he gave
rise to us we had a starting point he
didn't so that's why we're saying is
what caused it it has to be good
that's my claim
i'm just trying to say yeah it's just
thought-provoking now just something
yeah yeah yeah because it is like i said
it's a very strong question to ask what
caused this
and why are the people claiming that
there is an entity that goes there
it's a two separate question yeah what
do you think the purpose of god is okay
good so what we say is